carrusel de las artes
[Música]
hasta el día olivares
hola a todos y bienvenidos a este
carrusel dedicado a la música y para eso
te invitamos a descubrir el mundo mágico
del festival río loco de toulouse
no lo sé
río lo que nos abre sus puertas al borde
del río ya dónde tu luz de tolosa
descubriremos circos ambulantes
instalaciones sonoras como la de la
compañía la cresta las sonoridades
latinas protagonistas de este evento
musical el uruguayo jorge drexler nos
habló de su nueva conexión con el
público francés poses femeninas en la
ciudad rosa como la de silvia pérez cruz
que nos deja una huella multicultural
desde nueva york la banda spanish harlem
orchestra enciende el público francés
navegamos con su creador óscar hernández
[Música]
sí
el festival de música aquí en francia no
es un verdadero festival sino incluye a
toda la familia a los artistas locales y
a los artistas de todo el mundo y de
todos colores
[Música]
actividades artísticas y circos
ambulantes bajo un calor intenso
voluntarios como valentín fueron
movilizados como humidificadores humanos
y fijaban de hace 40 grados estamos en
plena canícula proponemos a la gente
mojarles como un mini jugador móvil todo
el mundo medio de metal sonrisa y
sonrisas
paseando por este viaje sonoro en el
corazón del festival río loco de
toulouse nos encontramos con esta
insólita instalación llena de sorpresas
sonoras y estamos aquí con el creador de
esta instalación hola alec dime qué es
esto es una instalación que se llama
orchestra nya es la compañía la cresta
somos una compañía que venimos de
barcelona y bueno nos hemos montado
estos instrumentos que son con material
reciclado podemos empezar por esta de
aquí
ser un bombo de lavadora esto es un
perchero son unas cuerdas debajo con sus
afinadores y simple entonces tiene toda
su electrónica tenemos una caja donde va
todos los efectos y sale por cascos
donde recibimos la señal modulada por
los efectos
otro instrumento cascón ya en este caso
podemos jugar dos personas a la vez con
los cascos pero hay una tercera persona
que puede entrar aquí dentro se pone el
casco y la misma estructura hace de
amplificación de todos los elementos que
hay aquí fuera pueda intentar
genial me lleva a casa ahora
como lo verano me quedaría aquí todo el
festival pero tenemos que seguir este
viaje sonoro por río loco
sí sí
buenas noches toulouse bolso a tu luz tu
corazón
siempre contracorriente
[Música]
sólo se deja
cuando se va la gente
y entonces se hace
se suelta el pelo y me canta
tenemos la suerte de estar con jorge
drexler aquí en el festival río loco de
toulouse somos testigos de esa conexión
con su público francés muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros jorge hola qué
tal es un gusto para mí esta es mi
primera vez en toulouse de hecho en
francia tocó muy poco por razones que
todavía no bueno yo lo que creo que
trabajamos tanto del otro lado del
atlántico en latinoamérica este que a
veces nos ha quedado poco tiempo hace
muchos años que no venía francia estamos
aquí para hablar también de tu obra y
más precisamente de lo que te trajo aquí
a francia y es tu último álbum que se
llama tinta y tiempo que es para ti la
tinta que es para ti el tiempo la tinta
y el tiempo junto con la hoja en blanco
son los tres ingredientes para la
escritura
quizás el más importante es el tiempo de
los tres para mí no escribir es un acto
de fe y un acto de paciencia es uno se
enfrenta a la hoja en blanco y es una
batalla que pierde casi todas las veces
de hecho la portada del disco es una
hoja en blanco y en la pandemia
particularmente fue muy difícil y a mí
me costó mucho escribir el aislamiento
entonces
me repetía a mí todo el tiempo y de ahí
viene esa canción tranquilo tinta y
tiempo como que las cosas lo que tenga
que ser escrito será escrito tocar
tocar
y
en ese álbum está el tema la canción
tocarte que significa tocar por el acto
de tocar otra persona era realmente una
de las cosas que más este que se
volvieron más peligrosas inclusive que
echamos en falta la canción dice jugarte
la vida buscarme la ruina no a jugarme
la vida es que realmente en ese momento
cuando escribimos la canción una de las
personas que la escribió
acababa de venir de encontrarse con su
novia que no se veían hace tres meses y
no pudieron tocarse porque estaban
todavía la estaban cada uno tenía
personas sensibles en su casa que no
quería exponer entonces estar frente a
un ser querido y no poder tocarlo es uno
de los de los dolores más profundos que
puede tener una persona y tocar te habla
de eso no estar como hacer cometer todas
las imprudencias este sanitarias que no
pudimos cometer beber del vaso de otra
persona de abrazarse con un extraño
compartir música en una misma habitación
cantar dentro de una habitación muchas
personas y como no hablar de la
referencia que eres para américa latina
muchas referencias e incluso que te
llevaron a colaborar con otros artistas
que también son referencias habló por
ejemplo de joaquín sabina de cerrar de
mercedes sosa- de chaquira tanganas más
recientemente tienes alguna colaboración
que ha sido insólita o la más insólita
de tu carrera pues mira de las cosas más
insólitas que hice fue la colaboración
con ze tangana con mucho porque los dos
tenemos estilos muy diferentes pero nos
admiramos mutuamente y yo siempre digo
que a mí me interesa mucho más trabajar
con personas que son diferentes de mí
porque yo ya llevo 30 años haciendo esto
un poco me aburro de mí
esa fue una colaboración realmente
insólita que me llevó a escribir de
manera diferente tocarte es la canción
que escribimos con él precisamente queda
alguna conexión musical con américa
latina' yo estoy conectado y eternamente
con américa latina' de hecho estoy más
conectado con américa latina desde que
vi una españa porque a través de mi
carrera en españa el gran gran regalo
que me ha hecho la música en mi vida es
iberoamérica bueno muchas gracias jorge
muchas
gracias
[Música]
bien
me haces bien
[Música]
y así ha sido
y llegada desde españa junto a la farsa
circus a bandas a silvia pérez cruz
opera con magia desde el escenario
francés una magia hecha con flamenco
fado tango etcétera etcétera sin olvidar
obviamente el ingrediente final su voz
[Música]
tú puedes
y tengo una voz que parece que se va a
romper y nunca se rompe no tiene que ver
con el volumen sino lo que se da un
equilibrio entre la humildad y la
seguridad seguridad de que hago lo que
amo hay un timbre que me ha tocado unos
padres que me han enseñado a contar la
búsqueda de un lenguaje propio mis
propias palabras que mezclan muchos
estilos mi actitud que creo que es
honesta y de apertura y eso eso a veces
hace un efecto espejo que la gente se
también se abre y suele haber momentos
muy emocionantes de limpieza no sé es
una especie de purga colectiva
del se menta el amor
silvia pérez cruz presenta su último
álbum llamado farsa género imposible un
trabajo de cinco años que interpreta hoy
con la banda farsa circus band entre las
canciones figura la música original de
la película de animación josep todo el
disco está compuesto por canciones que
he compuesto yo trabajando con otros
artistas desde rocío molina la bailaora
desde álvaro brechner en cine giuseppe
la banda sonora de una película de
animación francesa y este disco recoge
todo eso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tenemos la gran inmensa
inconmensurable suerte de estar aquí
junto a oscar hernández que ya me
presentamos obviamente el representante
de la spanish harlem orchestra
[Música]
nacido y criado en nueva york de padres
latinos ese lugar diego
y algo muy importante sobre el
desarrollo de nuestra cultura y ese
desarrollo fue muchas veces a través de
la música
[Música]
20 años de carrera y 3 premios grammys
óscar hernández el creador nos reveló el
secreto de tanta fama
y estoy súper claro super claro en
mantener esa línea y ser honesto y
aparte más importante hacer lo que amo
entiende para mí el amor sobre esta
música es súper profundo con un respeto
es la fórmula mantenernos claro en la
identidad de nuestra cultura en puede
ser el
colombiano peruano puertorriqueño cubano
o chileno argentino que lo que sea
nosotros llevamos un algo en común que
es súper importante para nosotros seguir
demostrando la cultura nuestra y en mi
caso a través de lo que yo hago que es
la música
los embajadores de la salsa neoyorquina
cumplen 20 años y entre sus éxitos está
la música de la serie sex and the city
fue algo lindo no sabe él cuando lo
hicimos que iba a tener el éxito ahora
son 30 años después ha tenido un éxito
increíble pues
con todo un tonto un tipo de punto
hasta el tiempo que no lo escucho pero
súper orgulloso ya es hora de
despedirnos de esta edición 2022 de río
loco una edición de carrusel de las
artes dedicadas a la música 100% música
aquí desde toulouse un regalo el último
concierto de río loco gracias y abierto
la orquesta del barrio
ahora quiero
echando cándida y no sabroso
[Música]
echando candela
esta es la verdad del barrio ahora